bonsoir bonsoir Alexis alors pas mal de
choses au menu vous vouliez commencer
entreprendre notre conversation ce soir
avec ce tournant qu'on peut qualifier
d'important ce soutien occidental en
Ukraine qui se voit étoffer par cette
ouverture de Joe Biden prêt autorisé
d'autres pays à fournir à l'Ukraine des
avions de combat de fabrication
américaine certaines ont écrit tout à
l'heure en disant mais attention c'est
pas pour demain matin relativisions
importantes de tout ça votre point de
vue là dessus en fait les deux choses
sont pas mutuellement exclusives c'est à
dire que c'est vrai que c'est important
potentiellement présumant que ça se
concrétise c'est vrai que c'est pas
demain la veille non plus que ça va être
utilisé en Ukraine d'ailleurs on prévoit
au moins plusieurs mois ne serait-ce que
pour former les Ukrainiens que
éventuellement utiliseraient utiliseront
ces armes là en même temps ce qui est
important de noter c'est que ça
s'inscrit pas dans un vase clos et si
vous vous posez simplement la question
élémentaire suivantes est-ce que depuis
le début de ce conflit là qui remonte on
l'appelle un peu plus d'un an maintenant
est-ce qu'on est en mode davantage
d'escalade ou de désescalade la réponse
elle est évidente on est en mode
escalade parce que c'est pas encore une
fois le premier épisode de la
rappelez-vous simplement on n'a pas le
temps ensemble de faire tous les
exemples mais ne serait-ce qu'au cours
des derniers mois on a eu l'épisode par
rapport au possible les équipements
anti-aériens à la base on disait bah on
n'est pas sûr d'en envoyer finalement on
a décidé d'envoyer on a pris on a eu un
débat un petit peu similaire par rapport
au fameux tank au char d'assaut léopard
notamment les Allemands qui étaient plus
récalcitrants on a fini par en envoyer
là on s'embête peut-être encore dans le
même film par rapport assez F-16 là et
encore une fois les seulement en
guillemets question d'équipement
militaires regardez encore les sanctions
une énième ronde de sanction
occidentales annoncée dans les dernières
heures contre la Russie sanction soit de
temps passant nouvelle sanctions qui
vont dans les deux sens parce qu'en même
temps la Russie a également annoncé dans
les dernières heures des sanctions
contre principalement là des Américains
quelques 500 personnes américaines
incluent à peu près une cinquantaine
demande ce congrès donc on est
clairement en mode escalade et l'autre
point je crois fondamental à réaliser
là-dessus c'est que si le plan
occidental et je lisais les propos d'un
ex conseiller du président
qui à cet effet là il y a quelques
heures si le plan occidental a plein de
craignait plein américain pardon c'est
d'armer et d'armée et d'armée davantage
l'Ukraine jusqu'à tant que la Russie se
retient une latéralement de l'Ukraine
mais je m'excuse à vous dire comme ça
mais la chose principale dont on va
devoir s'ammer cette patiente parce que
croyez moi que c'est pas demain la
veille que Vladimir Poutine
sur des mois pour pas dire
potentiellement même des années et d'un
point de vue humain à chaque jour c'est
ce pauvre pays là qui se fait détruire
de plus en plus des civils qui sont tués
des femmes qui sont violées donc c'est
simplement d'une grande tristesse
actuellement c'était infinie une
tragédie à chaque jour qui passe comme
vous le soulignez à juste titre Raphaël
on fermait la parenthèse là dessus
puisqu'on faut se garder un peu de temps
pour parler de round de santé parce que
là si on en croit ce qui transparaît
dans les médias américains le gouverneur
de la Floride adversaire de jadis plus
coriace de Donald Trump mais serait sur
le point spécialisé sa candidature oui
potentiellement dès la semaine prochaine
l'utilisation du mot jadis est bonne
Alexis on dit souvent que six mois c'est
une éternité en politique ça s'en est un
sacré bon exemple parce que
littéralement il y a 6 mois on mesurait
potentiellement monsieur De Santis face
à Monsieur Trump en vue des primaires de
2024 monsieur de santé c'était en avance
dans plusieurs de ces sondages là à
aujourd'hui à la veille ou la case
veille du lancement de sa candidature
officielle écoutez dépendant des
sondages il est maintenant 35 40 45
points en arrière le dernier que sondage
des confitures complètes en à peine
quelques mois une erreur je crois
tactique extrêmement grave pour lui
c'est que sa mission première en amont
de l'annonce de sa candidature donc dans
les mois qui allaient mener à son
lancement de campagne c'était de
coaliser le vote non Trump derrière lui
et dissuadé des candidatures
républicains d'alternative or Alexis
qu'est-ce qu'on a pris également dans
les dernières heures on a un autre là
qui s'est manifesté son intérêt exact
dog burger le gouverneur du Dakota du
Nord et c'est Alexis votre réaction
c'est de dire dog qui je vous rassure
vous savez la compagnie d'à peu près 99%
de la population américaine
le point étant que lorsqu'on est rendu
avec honnêtement le danonyme tâcherons
comme ça qui eux-mêmes sentent que ça
pourrait être bon pour eux de lancer
dans la course et que Monsieur De Santis
a échoué complètement pour ce qui est de
dissuader donc candidatures
républicaines donc il y a ça d'un point
de vue tactique et d'un point de vue
stratégique que je fasse après mais il
semble s'être entouré depuis les
derniers mois en particulier d'Aix
conseillé de tête Cruze Center du Texas
qui s'était présenté pour la présidence
en 2016 le mentionne parce que Monsieur
De Santis depuis des mois semble vouloir
calquer la stratégie de Monsieur Cruz
c'est à dire essayer de se présenter
comme étant plus plus pur que pur
idéalement la candidat le plus
conservateur inimaginable et ça écoutez
ça a pas fonctionné pour Monsieur Cruz
en 2016 et ça risque de ne pas
fonctionner pour Monsieur Dos Santos non
plus en 2024 donc évidemment on est
encore très tôt présumant qu'il se lance
la semaine prochaine ça va être la ligne
de départ sur ce qu'il faut elle dit que
la ligne de départ elle est très très
loin de celle de Monsieur Trump
se produire leur rappelle qu'en toile de
fond on y reparlera un autre moment il y
a cette bataille avec Disney autre
chapitre des années qui renonce à
construire un campus de près d'un
milliard de dollars dans son parc de
d'attraction de la Floride bref très
rapidement le seul c'est parce que le
point sur destiné est extrêmement
important il est directement lié avec ce
que je mentionnais il y a un instant
lorsqu'on parle de c'est d'être plus pur
que peut aider logiquement parce que un
certain point on a l'air carrément
intransigeant et la bataille qui
politiquement était à l'avantage de
Monsieur De Santis face à dîner il y a
peut-être un an est en train de vraiment
tourner au vinaigre pour lui donc c'est
un bon exemple effectivement la
dynamique présentement Joe Biden et le
plafond de la dette tout le monde donc
lui il est parti évidemment au Japon
pour le G7 mais pendant ce temps-là ça
négocie et ça négocie ferme à Washington
on en est où on en est si on croit le
président républicain de la Chambre des
représentants qui viennent me Coretti en
mode pause présentement ah bon donc on
aurait cessé pour les négociations sauf
quand même temps il faut réaliser qu'on
ait une semaine qui semble dans
l'ensemble avoir été assez productive
donc on sait parler jusqu'à très très
récemment et ça semble avancer de part
et d'autre il faut aussi noter que Joe
Biden aurait envoyé un message à c'est
clair là c'est propre troupes que l'idée
d'utiliser le 14e amendement je fais ça
bref là aussi là c'est à dire essayer de
contourner avec une utilisation assez
novatrice une interprétation c'est assez
novatrice de la Constitution américaine
contourner le Congrès et faire en sorte
que le président américain
unilatéralement relève le plafond de la
dette ça serait exclu donc monsieur
Biden planche et veut continuer à
plancher sur une entente avec le Congrès
même si on l'a pas aujourd'hui gardons
en tête que l'échéancier est quand même
pas pour demain et je maintiens que je
serai le premier surpris même si ça
prend encore un peu de temps même si on
flirt avec disons un saut dans le goût
je serai assez surpris merci qu'on ne
finisse pas trop tard par s'entendre non
seulement parce que les conséquences
économiques seraient désastreuses
potentiellement et parce que les
conséquences politiques pour tous les
acteurs en jeu inclure monsieur mcartit
monsieur Biden serait également donc un
énorme institatif à finir par s'entendre
donc monsieur baiden peut dormir sur ses
deux oreilles au Japon en ce moment oui
même si il sera pas très longtemps non
exactement en terminant rapidement le
rapport de RAM la on a beaucoup parlé
médiatiquement aux États-Unis sur
l'ingérence russes dans les élections de
2016 en fait les liens possibles avec
Donald Trump qu'est-ce qu'on doit
retenir de tout ça est-ce que ça peut
avoir une incidence savoir une instance
dans la mesure de notre chambre va
continuer à en parler en parler en
parler parce que pour lui disons que ça
valide essentiellement exactement ça
théorie de la chasse aux sorcières la
réalité est plus complexe que ça en
quelques secondes je vous dirais que ça
va être récupéré politiquement de façon
extrêmement tribale et partisane comme à
peu près n'importe quoi depuis des
années pour pas dire un peu plus
longtemps que ça aux États-Unis en même
temps ce qui est également vrai c'est
qu'il y aurait lieu je crois un examen
de conscience de part et d'autre encore
une fois donc climat
on n'aura pas ça dans un climat aussi
tribal aussi polarisé aussi difficile
et je pense qu'on est de la dans ce
genre de dynamique pour encore longtemps
d'autant plus que les primaires
approchent la présidentielle et tout ça
une chose que vous êtes là pour apporter
les nuances nécessaires merci beaucoup
Raphaël c'est bonne soirée